[Musique]
l'hymne national ukrainien résonne dans
les rues de montréal
des gens se sont rassemblés devant le
consulat général de la fédération de
russie pour démontrer leur soutien
envers l'ukraine dix jours après
l'invasion russe au piano cet ukrainien
d'origine ma vie ne sera jamais comme
auparavant il y avait avant 24 février
2000 vendeuse et après à québec les
drapeaux ukrainien aussi flotte dans les
airs olena vit au canada depuis dix ans
moi je peux pas expliquer la douleur qui
chaque de nous re et simple on essaie
d'appeler chaque jour juste nos amis
pour savoir est ce que tout le monde est
en vie ses proches sont toujours en
ukraine et ne compte pas la quitter nos
mères est acquis hier présentement il ya
beaucoup de gens comme elle qui veulent
pas partir elle demande aux forces de
l'otan que le ciel de son pays soient
mieux protégés pour que les civils
soient en sécurité et si l'otan
n'intervient c'est la guerre personne ça
mais peut-être lié à notre moyenne et
des avec les avions militaires son
groupe d'amis crois que l'armée
ukrainienne est en mesure de se défendre
au sol mais qu'elle n'a pas la capacité
d'arrêter les russes dans les airs cette
situation les paralyse
alexandra a tout simplement arrêté de
travailler on pense toujours à nos
proches on pense toujours à la situation
dans le pré on écoutait les nouvelles
toujours tous les jours à tous les soirs
il n'y a pas d'autre choix selon eux les
décideurs doivent durcir le temps ou
plus vite sans quoi les conséquences
seront désastreuses
six auteurs pensent que la guerre il
vient pas
à l'europe c'est une erreur majeure
c'est aussi ce que pense oksana arrivé
au québec il y a 6 ans et poutine et ne
veut pas arrêter juste nous prendre
comme tant d'autres sa famille est prise
en ukraine elle habite à quelques pas de
la centrale nucléaire attaqué vendredi
supporter ça c'est vraiment très
intéressant quand tu comprends que
peut-être demain quand nous avons eu
plus
de loin ces ukrainiens regardent
impuissants les leurs avec fierté on est
encore une crème libre et on va sur ses
shows ils espèrent que leur message soit
entendu
ici marie pierre merci radio canada
québec